e
so um let's get started welcome
everybody to the general purposes
committee meeting uh fire alarm
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated vacate the offices via the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assembly in Hy Square on the green and
officers will assist you and advise you
when it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber would every please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
that they do not are not used to make or
receive phone calls while the meeting is
in
progress um please note this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public the meeting will also be recorded
and will subsequently be broadcast on
the internet does anyone intend to film
the meeting no I'm looking at you
suspiciously in the back there no thank
[Laughter]
you okay um offic and attendance we have
ingred brown the head of legal and
Democratic democracy and monitoring
officer uh Sonia Godfrey uh head of HR
and Sarah Flack employee relations lead
and they will be able to answer all the
questions you've come up in your reading
for this
meeting uh does anyone have any uh
Declarations of interest in items of
business on the agenda for this meeting
I didn't think so uh any apologies oh
have I missed apologies sorry any
apologies KY do so Linda Wright nothing
and John
Nichols
okay uh um minutes of the previous
meeting um to approve the minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of October uh
the copy was attached to the agenda pack
can I have a proposer and a seconder
please proposed Steve alurn seconded
John Davis thank you uh are we agreed
agreed thank you uh minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 12th
of December 23 again the uh pack was
attached to the agenda
can I have a proposer Karina thank you
and Trisha Austin thank you uh do we
agree it's going very well this okay to
the meat of the um uh meeting now uh
Phase 2 HR policy review uh can I ask
Sonia to introduce this to us
please yes thank you um so Phase 2 HR
policy review as general purposes
committee you've been asked to review
the proposed report and are asked to
consider and adopt a new other types of
leave policy and two revised policies of
restructuring redundancy and recruitment
policy and procedure with effect from
the 1st of February
2024 uh so the review of HR policies
continues uh with a number of phases
outlined and ensuring robust policies
are in place is essential um obviously
for Prov providing Clarity and
consistency thus ensuring legal
compliance and best practice
establishing Fair practices and
promoting a positive work culture within
our
Council so with regards to corporate
implications uh from a financial and
value for money perspective there are no
financial implications arising directly
from the refresh of the restructure and
redundancy policy or the recruitment
policy and procedure however there is
the potential for the new other types of
leave policy to generate a small amount
of additional costs it is anticipated
that any cost associated with the
approval and implementation of this
policy will be very low and there for
containable within existing
resources so from a legal perspective as
indicated within the report these
policies have been developed to improve
practices across the council and they
address issues of concern highlighted in
the independent monitoring officer
report so risk management perspective HR
policies serve to define behavioral
expectations promote fairness compliance
and efficiency within the organization
and the risk associated with failing to
implement new or revised HR policies May
potentially expose the council
throughout a policies we're changing
laws industry standards and
organizational
needs so from a corporate perspective it
is important that the council's HR
policies you know are updated and
reviewed and in supporting this review
extensive research has been carried out
to look at best practice organizational
needs as well as considering the
policies and procedures in place to
other comparable local authorities so
the revised policies have been de
developed in line with acast and L
relevant legislation and consideration
also from a HR perspective so around
sort of practical issues that have
emerged whilst operating within existing
policies and procedures so our review of
policies continues as a previously
mentioned and the final versions of
policies identified within phase two um
are obviously included in the report
that we've shared with you so um just as
an overview the main change to the
restructure and redundancy policy
applies in the case where a position is
being deleted and the employee affected
is put at risk of redundancy and there
is no suitable role identified in the
update ated policy the employee will
receive the same status as if they were
on notice of redundancy this means that
they will have priority for any suitable
alternative roles and be given priority
with any internal job
applications recruitment policy and
procedure there are a few proposed
changes to this policy one of the more
significant changes that managers will
be able to advertise some job vacancies
internally for a period of only one week
and the current policy requires all
vacancies to be advertised internally
and externally for at least two
weeks um
other types of leave policy this is a
new policy covers types of leave that
are not covered in any other policies it
also allows one additional day of paid
leave each year for voluntary work which
has been requested by several members of
Staff in recent months and staff must
meet the requirements set out in the
policy to
qualify so with regards to consultation
I can confirm that the the draft
policies were agreed by CMT before
commencing a 30-day consultation period
with the trade unions Unison and gmbb
and staff and during the consult ation
period feedback was received from staff
and Unison feedback did not result in
any significant changes to the draft
policies and only some minor changes in
wording were applied to the proposed
policies um positive feedback has been
received from both staff and Unison in
regards to the one-day paid leave each
year for voluntary work as covered
within our new other types of leave
policy so the policies presented within
this report if agreed and adopted by
general purposes committee will go live
on the 1st of February 24 thank you
thank you do members have any questions
comments
John uh thank you chair
um thank you for uh a concise and and I
think easy to understand report um just
one question and and and it may relate
to the the business of people's jobs
being vulnerable and obviously them
getting priority I wondered why the
change was made where the managers will
only need to advertise internally for a
week is that to streamline and
accelerate the process because within a
week obviously they're not you know if
there's no interest in a week why would
there be in two
internally yes so currently when we it's
mainly cumbrance that we have the issue
with if you like so we don't really
offer external cumbrance now now that
we've come away from the shared service
it's mainly internal so if somebody is
wanting to step up into a role it's only
for a set period of time we've got
candidates internally that's the sort of
circumstances we mean anything where we
need to be competitive they will still
need to go out externally for so this
gives you built-in flexibility that tiny
bit Yeah flexibility for managers yeah
thank
you thank you chair I've got a few I'm
afraid is that okay um I want to know
under the rest restructure and
redundancy kind of what discretion heads
of service have before something becomes
a restructure so we've got several new
heads of service including ing if if if
somebody comes in as a head of service
and looks at who there is there and what
roles there are and thinks oh we could
really do with tweaking that a bit does
that count as a restructure does how how
does something like that work a sort of
small tweak that's my first
question I'm sure you can add to this
Sarah um what what we're doing now going
forward is the HR working closely with
heads of service on any changes they
want to make departmentally so
absolutely there may be some tweaks that
just need to be made um it might be just
change in in job description content um
it might be potential acting up within
certain roles um whatever that looks
like hii will support and give you know
appropriate advice um we also present on
a quarterly basis to CMT a restructure
overview so from a CMT perspective we
are aware corporately as to what
restructures are happening and kind of
prioritization of those restructures as
well um but yeah absolutely if it is
just minor tweaks then then we would be
working and giving the right advice
around that I don't know Sarah if
there's anything else you wanted to add
to that all I would say is where we need
to comply legally with any consultation
periods we will do so so it will depend
on the nature of the changes to the
advice we give great thank you that was
the first one um the second one is just
a tiny little I suppose probably
grammatical ex English teacher thing uh
which is under the right to be
accompanied at the beginning of that
section you've suddenly got you have the
right to be accompanied where everything
else has said the employee this and the
employee that so for consistency can I
suggest that we change that to the
employee has the right to be accompanied
and can I ask this is quite obviously
necessarily legalistic sounding document
is there going to be or is there a sort
of simpler version for so if you're a a
an employee threatened with redundancy
and you're feeling really panicked is
there a simpler version about these are
your rights and so on for an employee
who maybe doesn't have backing of a
union or
whatever yes we have guidance that sits
um on the Internet site um that's going
to all be taken down and re reput up in
a format that everybody can utilize
quite friendly brilliant thank you and
the under recruitment we've got
obviously that people who are under
threat redundancy Etc are the first to
be considered for vacancies I'm
wondering we had a long discussion at
overie in scrutiny the other week about
the use of temporary staff and agency
staff and I'm wondering what rights if
any people have who've maybe been
working for us via an agency for a long
time when an appropriate vacancy comes
up will they get considered before
external applicants or do they have just
the same right as an external
applicant so agency workers they would
have the same as external candidates
however people on fixed term contracts
with with us do have the right yeah okay
brilliant and the last one is an
observation rather than a question which
is I'm really pleased to see about the
volunteer days and can I suggest that we
also consider the possibility that
either those or in addition we offer
employees learning days where they have
the opportunity to learn something
that's not directly relevant to their
work an organization I work with work
with a lot of local authorities on this
it's a really good motivator for
employees and it actually broadens
people's scope in all sorts of ways and
I'm very happy to have a conversation
with you about that separately but it's
it's a really beneficial thing for
employees and I'd really recommend it
thank
you
Steve yes thank you CH I just thinking
about that last point there I when I was
uh me member of Staff here I would have
put forward to I'm quite interested in
pubs so I think that might be a good
that might be a good idea but anyway um
I'm just so pleased that HR is now back
in
TDC um I didn't like it going out in the
first place but hey ho um so I'm really
pleased about that and and I
think as well every
Organization no matter who they are
should be frequently looking at the
policies especially HR policies
obviously to keep up with um keep up
with legal changes etc etc but I think
and uh the work as well between the
employer and the trade unions is
important and uh and I I'm just pleased
that obviously Unison and the GMB have
have made the little comments or small
comments but are in are in agreement as
a way forward and uh I just say keep
keep up the good work thank you
chair
Reena um I probably should know the
answer to this question but U is there
any uh information on apprenticeships
because I know you have had some in the
housing department which I think is a
really good thing and we want to I would
like to expand it to other departments
say is what are the rights of apprentice
apprentices are they the same as someone
having a permanent contract with TDC
thanks so in in terms of the needs s
Department in terms of whether they want
to obviously have an apprentice that's
something that you know obviously we
would give advice on there's an
apprenticeship Levy that we can access
to obviously pay and support those types
of um work uh contracts um obviously
they would go on an apprentice contract
which would obviously be for as set
period with study leave as well within
that um and obviously you know depending
on how that goes you know in terms of
them obviously doing study alongside um
you know there may then be an
opportunity for them to apply for a role
but at least they've got you know know a
greater sort of skill set by working
with the council for that period of time
plus the you know additional
qualifications they may have gained in
that time to have an added advantage of
obviously looking for for work within
the council um so we we've got some more
work to do should we say around the sort
of L&D strategy and and having obviously
apprentices a part of that as
well can I just add to that is obviously
um possible to use the apprenticeship
Lev to upskill staff who are impost as
well and that's something certainly that
we're looking into within um law and
governance yeah I just I I just thought
one of the things um I'm I'm hoping that
we still retain and I I haven't got a
clue what I'm asking um for leave of
absence like you're talking about to
volunteer day
um do we still include uh will people
belong to uh the um army or you know go
on their two we training etc etc etc oh
is it oh I miss I missed that then must
close my eyes at that point um so we do
that's fine thank you we do um and and
just to say we've obviously added some
more within the content of that policy
as well so it's very clear um and we're
also going to be doing some additional
aren't we on some other policies for
managers as well well so they're aware
for people doing Union activity or Armed
Forces activity so they know what the
process is around that as
well
thank you chair it was really just to
update you because at the last general
purpose committee I agreed to have a
little look into what happened and and
why that that decision to increase hours
from 3 to 4 days didn't come to or
wasn't made at general purposes
committee and I have looked into it
spoken to everyone that I could possibly
speak to and really can confirm that it
was just a a a matter of a simple
misunderstanding of the process and
really derived from the fact that the
post was you know substantive post was a
full-time post so just a lack of
understanding derived from that but um
that's obviously been remedied thank
you yeah can I um thank um monitoring
officer for that update and and I think
it's important that it was addressed um
but I don't think think there's any
appetite for for pursuing it any further
among members I think we were quite
happy that it happened we were just
aware that it hadn't happened in an
appropriate way so we'll know next time
won't
we the verbal update uh do I have a
seconder thank you John
Davis uh do members agree fully noted
thank you that concludes the business
for this meeting I declare the meeting
closed at go it's been a long meeting 18
minutes I shall have to try
harder thank you very much everybody I'm
sorry I just realiz I just
realized